all right
let's do it
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
to
another episode of your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
and we're live and we strive
[Music]
to
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
ripping with griffin
we're doing it live once again day of
lot to talk about today so please keep
the trolling to a minimum
but i'm glad that you're here watching
with me and i appreciate it
so you know what let's just
get to the damn thing yes
so thank you for being here you know you
got your woo-woos and all that kind of
stuff and uh
i mean i'm excited to do it like this
i'm always trying new things and i
usually release the podcast today so i
say hey let's do it live on the day of
that the podcast comes out so
when i finish with this i got to get
right to the uploading it to the
the audio part of it but for right now
we're right here
i am going to be looking at the chat as
much as i can uh but you know please uh
keep your nonsense to a minimum you know
you know what i'm saying out there but
we're here
but listen uh i you know of course i
have a lot to talk about today i have my
i'll give my thoughts on everything that
has happened in the past week
but before i do that i have to take a
moment
see damn you know i told myself i wasn't
going to get emotional
it's just so weird how it's hitting me
right at this very moment but i do want
to say r.i.p to jeff scott
sorry he was the piano player
at the comedy store and he died
i don't even know why
anyways damn
look i'm sorry i'm not even trying to be
like this i was just fine i was just
singing i don't even know why it's like
this right now
but um
it just hit me hard and it's because
he was a good dude he really was he was
like he was like
a staple at the comedy store he played
he was the piano guy
every time he went up always positive
you know and it just hit me because
the um
it's like because of everything that's
going on with the pandemic and now
you're sitting at home and you're
thinking to yourself
who have i not seen you know what i mean
like
who of your friends and your family that
like you haven't
hit up
good grief what is look at me damn
i'm just a blubbering ass baby right now
i swear to god i wasn't emotional a
second ago and all of a sudden
anyways all right wussai
all right anyways let me get myself
together here
you know you're sitting at home right
now because of this pandemic and we
can't go out we can't go to restaurants
we can't go to movies we can't go to
places i can't go to like the comedy
store a place that
has been like home to me like where i
get to like
commune with like like-minded
individuals i get to see
friends enemies frenemies and we're just
all in this hallway with like you know
our jealousies and our envy and and our
friendships and all these things
you know and it's like it all got taken
away
and then you know so i never thought in
my head
that there are certain people
let me get another kleenex certain
people that i'd never see again
so i'm trying to take this time to tell
people
excuse me reach out to your loved ones
and not just your loved ones reach out
to those secondary friends that you like
took for granted that
you know you only see them at work right
or you only see or
maybe there's a gym you've been going to
for the last five years and like there's
that guy at the gym that you guys have
this great gym relationship you know
maybe reach out to that guy
maybe reach out to those people that you
just go like you think oh well you know
you take for granted that you see them
all the time
those are the people that you
that's what i'm thinking about
so damn am i gonna have to stop
good grief dude my goodness okay
anyways let's not let uh what's
happening in the world
take away from those relationships that
we took for granted you know
that's what i'm thinking about i'm
thinking about
all of that
this is so bizarre right now like i said
i was prepared to just
come on here do my live podcast talk
about all these things i wanted to talk
about but i am feeling overwhelmed with
emotions right now
because now i'm thinking about my mom
and i'm thinking about god do i see my
mom enough
you know have i have i been avoiding my
mom because i don't like dealing with
her dementia
you know you know you know it's like you
know what i'm saying it's like do we
like just being at home like i'm a
homebody right now like i never leave
i got this doorbell cam now you know for
the new place i'm at and so
and rachel she has it on her phone too
so every we get notifications when and
you know when people come to the door
even people cross our door you know
and rachel says to me like you never
leave i i you know
she looks she doesn't get any
notifications because will say eric
because it recognizes your face right
i just i like being here i like being at
home and i love doing uh my
twitch i love being on twitch every day
i love um
these opportunities that i've gotten
because of it and i just go i'm
appreciating being at home and i'm
appreciating her
i'm appreciate you know and so i'm just
really loving that this part of my life
but i can't forget about
those people out there who have touched
my lives and so
alright peter jeff scott and my
condolences go out to
everybody that has lost a loved one
during this pandemic that you didn't get
to see them you didn't get to hug them
and tell them that you love them
so i just really encourage
all of you
damn oh my goodness
this is kind of funny to me
anyways i encourage everybody to uh
reach out
to you get up once
[Music]
okay we're gonna get it together y'all
um thanks to hangover candle company
he don't even pay me or nothing i just
like this dude he sends me these candles
and it just they smell good so
i'm getting some zen piece right now
from the candle being here all right
it's like you know it's funny because
like as a comic
you handle things like with jokes and
humor
even in the worst possible times you
know but like right now i just
i don't know why going live and like
doing this like this is like making me
so emotional right now but it is what it
is
so anyways rip to jeff scott and
and my love goes out to everyone who has
you know lost a loved one
all right this is going to be weird to
listen to if you're just listening to
the audio
you're going to be like what the hell is
it with this dude all right anyways
let's get to it
so you know i i have a very weird
podcast i would like to you know if
you've listened to me regularly you know
my podcast is uh
you know my podcast i talk about
sometimes i'll talk about movies
sometimes i'll talk about a tv show then
other times i'll talk about whatever is
going on in the world
you know and i get a lot i really love
the feedback and responses i get for the
most part there are some trolls or
something just like i'm not even gonna
call you a troll some people just don't
know how to communicate their point
without it being a fight
you know sometimes people don't know how
to say like i disagree with you and this
is why people don't know how to have
that sort of common sense conversation
back and forth
without it turning into like you know
you're an idiot or this and that or
assuming you understand my political
meanings cause you don't
you [ __ ] don't know me like
that so don't come at me thinking i'm
like
right wing left wing don't come at me
with none of that you don't know me like
that
i am i like to take a common sense
approach to
whatever is going on and even if i have
my leanings towards
uh you know one side of the other it's
very much in the middle
so please don't assume
don't assume that you know me like that
you know when it comes to
that so the reason why i say that is i
want to talk about
all the stuff that has gone on in the
past week in a way that
i just want to take a common sense
approach at it you know i don't
lean towards one side or the other but
so anyways as we go into that you know
so i have my notes here just to to make
sure so you know what's the big thing
that happened so you know what we have
to talk about what i have to talk about
is
what happened with the um capital riot
you know
and you know this starts first i want to
go back
people have to understand their part in
this you know
you have this guy trump and i know that
there's a lot of trump supporters that
actually watch my podcast because
they'll send me any time you talk about
you just say the word trump and he
supporters his supporters will attack
you
as if everything this dude does is good
in their eyes they just attack you you
know whereas
i'm trying to tell you i don't look at
it like that i i will criticize
obama biden i will criticize i
criticized
when it was due when it was necessary i
will criticize
and it's the same thing with trump i
don't have to like this dude
now look when he came out he was
different
you know when he first came on the scene
to be the president
he was different it wasn't that usual
political talk and he spoke to a people
that they felt disenfranchised too
they felt left behind you know people
act like just because you're white
everything's hunky-dory you know there
are people out there that think like
if you're white people that are white oh
they're the man because
they must have everything going okay
it's not true
there's a lot of poor white people in
the country there's a lot of
lower middle class people who they also
have families
they also want health care they also
want good schools they also want their
neighborhoods to be taken care of
and they've just somehow forgotten
that's how they feel they
they feel they're forgotten no one knows
who they are
you know they had no one speaking for
them so this guy comes along and he says
hey i'm gonna get your coal mining jobs
back and he says all this stuff and
gets them riled up and then the other
side when hillary clinton was running
for office she's calling anybody
that wants to vote for donald trump
deplorable
you can't like what so at the time
before we know what we know now you
can't be a monday morning quarterback
at the time that was terrible that was a
terrible that was a stupid thing to say
to alienate a bunch of people instead of
trying to say
hey here's what i can do for you it just
became a
this is what he can't do this is what
this person can't do and just calling
names back and forth
and you know spewing out like facts that
like what are you talking about
just tell me what you're about tell me
what you could do better and that's just
not what happens in the political scene
so this guy comes along he's a con
artist he's got the right words he knows
what to say he's got a great team behind
him he's saying things like
you know drain the swamp and he's saying
all this stuff
right and then the left side especially
the media
and all you know they what do they do
they're they're just saying his name ad
nauseam over and over and over and over
again
you know he wins you know the guy wins
and now he's in office
and my problem with trump has always
been he's not qualified to be president
he's just not being a great businessman
or
being charismatic that shouldn't be
enough
okay he just he has no diplomacy he
doesn't understand that
you're the president not just for this
one party but for the whole country
this is what a lot of presidents have a
problem with by the way but i'm just
talking about the current one right
again i'm not leaning either way i'm
just saying this particular guy
he didn't have enough wherewithal
in politics to be a great president
no matter what you can list off some
things that he did well
the things that benefited you because
we're all selfish that way
so if you if you want to talk about
finances all right then yeah
would were our pocketbooks filled if
you're in a top percentile of money yeah
so you go all right i'll forgo i'll
forget everything else that went wrong
but this went well for me because we're
all selfish that way but come on
listing off a couple of good things
doesn't take away a bunch of the other
bad things
okay so guys in office and then
here's my problem all of the left media
entertainment wise stuff all they did
was help prop him up
they think that talking about him ad
nauseum every damn
day was helping the situation
no give us some different names of
people
every time they talked about trump they
should have talked about five democrats
that could have ran for office
so we could have those names in our head
no it was just non-stop trump
trump trump trump who's the most famous
democrat right now okay
you got now it's joe biden right but we
didn't want him
if you really think about it because he
if he wanted him he would have ran the
last
time right no bernie sanders
who they lambasted who they got rid of
who everybody's oh he's a socialist
a socialist right bernie sanders you
mean somebody that maybe would want to
give
every american two thousand dollars hmm
is that socialist
or is it just hey when people need help
we need to help them
isn't that kind of what we're doing
right now
uh isn't that what's happening isn't
everybody being like hey help me help me
help me
uh we need more than 600 we need 2 000.
and when that 2000 is not enough we're
going to be like uh yeah give me
5 000. but isn't that what bernie
sanders was about to
and now he that's all he was saying was
like hey let's just help the people that
need help
and now that's what this republican
administration is doing
and are they socialist anyway i digress
got rid of burns so bernie is the most
popular bernie who you know who
should run for office nancy pelosi
because that's the only name we hear
about
she might be the most famous democrat
right now just to a casual person
casual just casual uh person
hey do you know anything about politics
and they know well they would know nancy
pelosi because she's in the news all the
time right
that's what we needed to do with a
really good democratic candidate
to you know have that person be in the
news all the time but no
snl all they want to do is talk about
trump every cold open has to be
something about trump and then they
started winning emmys again nobody was
watching that show
that that show was like mcdonald's okay
it's just there
you go oh there's mcdonald's you know
some you know it's not good for you but
sometimes i'm in the mood for it
you know and then here comes the mick
rib that's trump
trump was the mcrib sandwich and then
they were like everybody's like oh the
mcrib is here let's go to mcdonald's and
then
talk about it all the time late night
talk show host
like we need another smug white guy in a
suit to tell
stale ass jokes every night at 11
o'clock on all the stations
you just change the channel it's like oh
another white guy in a suit telling dumb
jokes
oh let's go to another white guy in a
suit telling dumb jokes oh change the
channel
oh look hey guess what guys another
middle-aged white guy telling dumb jokes
then trump comes along resurrects all
their
stupid late night shows now it's just
trump trump trump all the time
trump trump trump trump right talk about
something else
talk about who you think should run if
you want to if you want to help
all they did was to fuel this guy's ego
he became like oh man look everybody
loves me everybody hates me
all right so anyway my point is
take your own accountability and your
own ownership of why
you think you know why this guy
rose to the heights that he rose all
right now
anyway i digress on that again
here comes now this capital riot that
happened
how do i feel about this capitol riot i
think it's terrible
it was an insurrection it was a planned
attack
a coup uh but here's the thing
you know what you know what i find funny
everybody's quiet
right now you know when the black lives
matter movement and
george floyd everybody had something to
say
all the white comedians and all all the
white actors and stars who felt like
well if i don't say something i'm gonna
be considered racist so i gotta put up
my black
thing on instagram and i have to say
something i have to make sure people
don't think i'm racist
so let me come out and say something
everybody had a lot to say
you know that george floyd tape
changed our thought process because if
you were a person
that really didn't think the police does
stuff like that
if you were a person that was like well
i'm sure this happens but it doesn't
happen
you know i don't know what your thought
process might have been
you know i don't but there are people
that think
listen i had my big brother for big
brothers of america okay
i've known him for 40 years all right
41 years actually i've known him all
right i remember
when rodney king the rodney king tape
came out
and the cops were beating the [ __ ] out
of him on tape
he said to me as a white jewish man he
said to me
i didn't believe it until i saw that
and this was a time when there was no
social media okay there was no social
media nothing like that
got lucky that that was caught on tape
but he said to me
until i saw that i didn't really believe
that the cops did anything wrong
and he was it changed him his thinking
so the i would venture to say that there
are still people out there that are like
well maybe that it doesn't happen or
come on you know whatever your feelings
are when you saw that george floyd tape
and you saw that guy with his hands in
his pockets and his
freaking knee on that guy's neck this
guy is no threat at all
at that time that was probably a wake-up
call for a lot of people like
uh this actually does happen and
we should do something about it all
right
well to me th this
capitol riot is an example once again of
the inequity of justice in the country
because
it listen everybody's said this already
and you can look
you know to be true yourself if those
were all
black people if if the black lives
matter movement
had attacked a capital like that do you
think they would have been walked out
like they're getting off a cruise
in the bahamas do you think like these
people were walking out of the capitol
like
waving they could have had lays on you
know and they should have been
you know the cops should have been
dancing and and you know
oh thanks for coming thanks for coming
to the capitol today
that's how they were walked out of that
place do you think that brown
and black people would have been walked
out of the capitol like that
no but no one thinks that
no one no one no one thinks that okay
now once again now here's what you don't
understand about me
i when the when during the black lives
matter movement when they were riding
and
burning down sephoras i was criticizing
that
i said it was stupid it is dumb to loot
and riot
in my opinion especially during a
pandemic you think the cops care about
your health and safety
you think that they're gonna like but
let's make sure all these prisoners are
six feet apart
no to me it was dumb to go looting and
riding during a pandemic
on top of i think looting and writing
don't really help the purpose right
that's how i feel about it see i was
strong about that
and then i had all these people hitting
me up talking about oh you don't
understand what rioting does you know
it helps where are those [ __ ]
now talking about these people
see because your same dumb justification
for people
looting and writing these people who
feel
that they are wronged even if we believe
that their reasons are wrong
okay but if they feel they are wrong and
this is the way
they want to express their anger and and
get out their frustrations is to go and
do this stuff at the capitol
why doesn't the justification work for
them it doesn't work for them why
because they're white
come on a majority of them are white
like don't
first of all stop acting like just
because somebody's white they're the man
okay like the world doesn't work like
that anymore okay
like if you're on the bus
and you're sitting next to a white guy
and you're on your way to work
that white guy he's not the man he's on
the bus with you
you understand this is about rich
poor middle class we're all separated by
money now
okay now to me the problem is
i know i'm all over the place because
i'm still emotional but it doesn't
matter this is what happens in a live
podcast so just bear with me people
trying to look over at the chat chat but
you know it is what it is
okay listen
we we don't we're not separated by like
that but let me tell you
my opinion of what's wrong with some of
the the the type of people that attacked
the the
the the capital all right these these
people who these
white people who feel like they're you
know
overlooked or that you know they feel
that their country's being taken over
these type of people you know what their
problem is
in my opinion they didn't get their
chance to be the man
see if you're under 50 right now if
you're under 50 let's say you're like 45
and under let's say
right you grew up in a time when the
world changed
you didn't get to be the man like if
you're a 40 year old
white guy right now and you come from a
family of racists
your father he got to use the n-word
whenever he wanted
your father he he saw a time when he
looked at the tv
and he saw all white people he
mostly white people he looked at the
time where his sports heroes were white
he looked he you know his his father and
his grandfather
they they're about babe ruth they're
about the baseball just mostly being
white they're about seeing
white celebrities and white stars and
and everybody being white and like why
yeah white people are running this place
your time came around and you had to see
michael jordan
michael jackson you had to look on tv
and see the
the cosby show you had to see like you
know
all of these people you had to see
people of color
dominating you had to see people of
color now
equal to and surpassing in some some
some areas you had to see the football
become
you know it's all black people now
basketball it's all black you have to
see
you now you look on tv right now and
every commercial was like interracial
every commercial is like black guy white
woman asian guy you know spanish girl
you know
you have to see all this stuff and
you're like hey what about us where's my
time
where's my time to shine like like my
father and my grandfather so
they they they never got to be the man
and they
they're upset about it they're just like
i want to be able to like walk into a
restaurant and be like
i don't i don't want this what is this
mangy mongrel what
they can't do that anymore you can't
discriminate
and they're upset about it that's what i
think i just think that they're
mad that they it passed over them and
now they have to
pull themselves up from their bootstraps
now you have to actually get an
education go to work
and take care of yourself and it has to
be on the merits of
who you are and what you do not just
your skin color
but your pocketbook and your influence
and all that stuff
and they're like well what i
i i want i want to be the man you got to
earn being the man now
and these [ __ ] can't do it they
can't do it they don't know how to do it
so they get taken over their ideologies
get
hijacked by people with a smarter
intellect that knows how to manipulate
that's trump trump's the kind of person
he knows how to manipulate
but you know the sad part about it is
those people will turn on trump like
this
like stop thinking trump is the leader
he's just a tool
he's just a tool of those type of people
that one guy with the antlers and stuff
that runs those type of like white
brotherhood organizations
they're just using trump right now
because he's the one right there
but once he's gone they don't care trump
thinks he
trump thinks these people love him they
don't they just love that he's
white and in power and so they can take
advantage of
what he position he's in and they can
use that as justification to do nonsense
but look how they turned on mike pence
already they they
want to turn on mike pence like this
just because mike pence is like
hey look he ain't no saint but i believe
he believes in the constitution
i believe my pence is going through
something right now where he's like damn
what did i do and his his reckoning is
going to come
but i think it's going to come within
himself listen these people that like
use christianity
these devout people i still feel like
there is something in them that knows
the difference between right and wrong
even though they've been misguided and i
think that he's coming to a point where
he's like damn
like mike pence must be sitting there
like what
i i supported you and you just go turn
on me like this
and then you're gonna have these people
talking about hang mike pence if i was
mike pence i'd be like all right
25th amendment you got to go right
so he's going through his thing right
now so that's what
he's got to deal with right anyways
so now you have so you have these people
who they do this thing and i'm not for
it just like i'm not for people
looting i'm not for black brown people
and those type of people looting
sephoras and
burning down foot lockers i'm not for
these people doing that but everybody's
quiet
like all the people who were getting on
me about like hey you don't understand
why people have to loot
where are you because these people are
saying the same thing to you but now
they're doing it
it's crazy all the hypocrisy it's just
hypocrisy
what what happened to blue lives matter
what happened to all that
where's the blue lives matter people
where you guys at
because five cops are dead or whatever
the number is all these people that were
beat up you just were beating cops up
so it so blue lives matter only when it
comes to when
it's involved with black people where
are you guys at
i don't know where you're at now i just
want to know where all the white people
that
had something to say about black lives
matter because you didn't want to come
off as racist
where are you why aren't you talking
about
these people that look like you they
look like you and they're out there
climbing the capitol wall
quiet quietest church mouse right now
where are you guys where are all the
comics that
all these liberal [ __ ] who have you
know all these progressive
liberal people who have to ad nauseum
talk about what they think is right and
wrong
you know but now when the people that
look like you
are doing the things now you have
nothing to say
where are you it's so frustrating to me
man
it's frustrating so frustrating
so here these people are man they listen
i don't i don't believe in their their
reasons
but i understand them i understand why
these people feel like
they're left behind or whatever their
dumb justifications are
to uh you know feel like
the the world is messed up and and
everyone's against them and trump
he took advantage of it but he
he opened up pandora's box because he
thought he thinks he's in control
of what's happening and i'm telling you
they're just taking advantage of the
situation
so he puts out this narrative that and
listen by the way
i'm not justifying this at all but i
understand trump too
he just don't want to give up power can
you even imagine being the president of
the united states
literally the most important person in
the world
the the most powerful position in the
world
by influence by everything why do people
like that even go into politics
citizen kane was like this you know
citizen the movie citizen kane or some
wells
you made this movie you know it's it's
basically about a dude who
accumulated a bunch of wealth and it
wasn't enough
once somebody like that gets a bunch of
wealth you know what they want to do
after that they want to be loved by the
people
they want power because power is not
with money
powers with influence and being able to
like
that's that's why politics is so
alluring to someone like that right
so he goes into politics but
imagine you're the president you've come
from
out of nowhere and you're about to lose
it's a grasp for power i'm not surprised
that on the day they're about to make
the count
he has this sort of speech to try to
like you know
hey you know rise up for me
it was an a an attempt to thwart
the count to me i think that trump was
doing what
what he was doing and saying that stuff
so then maybe they would not
do the count that day for fear of
whatever
and then they would like it would be
pushed or pushed off i think they were
also trying to get those
electoral ballots burn them
and then oh man we got to do this all
over again
i think it was an attempt to grasp hold
on to his power
but it got out of hand i don't care who
you are
if you are a trump supporter please
don't come at me and tell me that
you think that what he did was right now
here we go
the other point is they want to talk
about election fraud
listen i'd say somebody chance that
nancy pelosi is a narcissist and a
psychopath
uh that every single politician is a
narcissist and a psychopath
that i think that i think that's a part
of their personality
that's that's the only way you can get
into politics you got to be some you got
to be somebody that thinks
i know what's right and i am you know
i'm the one that can save you know
whatever but anyway that's neither here
nor there
my point i was making about nancy pelosi
is that's the only person we know about
like she could have ran for office and
everybody be like oh yeah nancy pelosi i
know that name
that's why they needed to get more names
out there talk about other people right
now
instead of talking about trump ad
nauseam in your echo chamber because
that's all it is is echo chambers
everybody just
saying the same thing to each other you
know start saying other things other
than trump
trump trump trump tell me buddhichedge
tell me bernie sanders
tell me you know all the different names
of people so we can get that in our head
but anyway all right
whoo i'm uh you know i started
emotionally and i hear where i am on
this and i'm angry about this stuff
um you know
you have to you have to anyways anyways
anyways so here are these people now
they want to use the justification of
this lie about voter fraud okay now
listen to me right now
if you're somebody who believes this let
me put this out to you
there's a thing called occam's razor all
right it's a philosophical
and they use this in movies all the time
and stuff but it basically is
the premise is the simplest explanation
is usually the right one
which one of these things do you think
is more plausible because
bipartisan i'm talking about republicans
and democrats in these states republican
states have said the election was
fine there was it wasn't rigged
the election was fine it's not just
democrats saying that
i'm talking about in those republican
states the
republican officials for the most part
are saying
this was a fair election
okay so what's more plausible
that there's some widespread conspiracy
that got
all of these officials all over the
united states
to agree to some election fraud or
the one guy in power that wants to stay
in power
is lying about election fraud which one
of those things is more plausible
like come on every election has some
shadiness because your people are
involved
selfish people who want to stay in power
okay selfish people that want to stay in
power are going to do some shady things
that's the
unfortunately that is in man's nature
is to look out for self-interest okay so
yes
there is going to be some some some
you're going to find some shadiness
okay but not 10 million votes
like so you're telling me that that
popular vote is go
like you believe that that popular vote
is is false
and there that let me tell you something
if the democrats
had the wherewithal if the democrats had
the political savviness
to rig an entire election [ __ ]
they would have done it
way before now okay
these people can't even agree with
themselves and you think they got the
whole country and all the officials to
get on their side
that's what you think so you think
that's plausible
but not that trump's lying really
really come on like that
didn't com use your common sense man
it's unbelievable so so the whole
premise is a lie
he just wants to stay in power and i get
it
do everything you can to stay in power
right he's not going to concede
you know he he doesn't want he wants to
be king who wouldn't
the power of the presidency it must be
intoxicating
for someone like that remember when he
was on tv firing people you're fired
you're fired he loves being loved he
loves it
okay so why wouldn't you know of course
he's gonna do
everything he can to stay in it all
right guys give me one second here okay
i i
i don't i got to blow my lows i remember
being on joe rogan
and he got on my case because it was
live at the time so i'm gonna go away
from the mic right now
actually i'm gonna turn the mic off and
it'll blow my nose all right so hold on
okay and we're back
anyways so of course the guy's
intoxicated by power and wants to keep
it he's gonna do everything he can all
right but it got out of hand
he these people are well more well
organized they knew what they were doing
they planned it out and i'm sure there's
going to be more stuff like that
okay but these people are dumb can i
tell you something
i don't listen when you're doing a live
podcast it's just a scream
stream of consciousness and we're just
yapping right now and this is what i do
and i love actually love to do this so
you know if you're going to put your
comments up and be like what are you
talking about you're all over the place
yeah i know i'm all over the place i
don't care you know what
turn off my podcast then move along i
don't care about you move along
all right so anyways
here's the thing all right um
[Music]
you know looters i thought it was dumb
right when the looters for black lives
matter or whatever whatever happened
with george
all these people you know what i think
is really really really stupid about it
you're on camera people are waving at
the camera
like these young people of this
generation they think that they're
just they think that they're immune to
like
law and justice you're on camera
like if i own sephora my my video
footage
i i'm categorizing that i'm hiring
people all right i need you to screen
cap
every single person that you can find
that's in the store that you have a good
picture of
and i'm putting that out there i'm
making sure that stuff is that stuff is
being investigated and i'm going to make
sure that those people are put brought
to justice
and they will do that trust me we're
just not hearing about it
but trust me there was that that that
one white guy who stole the surfboard
who's on camera with no mask on just
looking like hey
if they find that guy he going to jail
it's the same thing with these stupid
capital looters you want to talk about
idiots i mean idiots
these people are waving at the camera
they got they're filming themselves
there was like a documentary guy there
filming
you're a part of it dude you're a part
of an insurrection
that's a capital offense i think you
could get the death penalty i think you
know
look i'm just speaking hyperbolically
right now i
who knows but i think that that's you're
you're an enemy of the state you're
trying to and you're
on camera and then these people
they think they could just fly home
these [ __ ] are on camera
trying to take over the united states
trying to like you know
they they they're looting the capital
they're they're in there
being violent killing cops and then they
think they can just get your carry-on
bag and go on a delta flight home
really [ __ ] really you think
that you could go to the our our our
our government building where the vice
president
the speaker of the house a bunch of
senators and
our congress is in session and you think
you can threaten their lives and you can
get on a delta flight home really [ __ ]
really like these people
are so stupid
they're stupid and looters are stupid
people who think that looting a [ __ ]
sephora is going to push their agenda
forward and make change
are idiots just like these dumb
white hillbilly [ __ ] who thought they
could climb over a wall
and do all that nonsense they were doing
and then get on a delta flight home
these people are stopped at the airport
like yeah um
this is you on video um at the capitol
that's you waving at the camera right
yeah [ __ ] you want to know fly list now
like
i mean this is the this is
the nonsense it's the hypocrisy that's
why both sides are quiet right now
that's why a lot of people are like the
only thing we're all saying
that we agree with and you have to agree
with this too i mean i guess you don't
have to i mean you just say what you
want
but if it was all black people
at the at the capitol if it was all
brown people
if it was a majority of those type of
people climbing over walls
you think only five people would be dead
on
on their side too by the way
you know what i mean you think please we
all know the truth in that situation
so that's why you also if you're white
you're at home
kind of going oh wow here's another
example of how
justice is not the same for white people
and for non-white people it's not the
same
just even how we approach it and how we
look at it how they're categorizing how
they're
how they're talking about it on the news
how they're like you know oh the
this how they're talking about the cops
how they're talking about these people
it's like so i don't understand why it
just
it feels so organized somehow of like
you know it's not this like brash
emotional attitude about they're really
like
well this is what's happening here you
know they're they're going step by step
about
those people they know who they are and
it's like i don't know
the whole [ __ ] is a nightmare let me get
back to my notes so i make sure i don't
miss out on things that i wanted to talk
about because i'm just going in today
huh
uh all right
here's something we should talk about
just to get let me just get back on
track here and i really appreciate
everybody for being here
watching live i appreciate you all um
let's talk about trump being kicked off
twitter okay
now guys
twitter is not government run
that is a private organization who sells
ads
that is a that is an organization that
tries to make
money trump
did not lose his freedom of speech the
[ __ ] got a
press room in his house right now that
he can go talk to people whenever the
hell he wants
he could still have a press conference
he could still
make your own app bro if you wanted to
make a website
if you wanted to he could do whatever
the hell he wants he can still he still
has his freedom of speech
what he lost is his convenience of
social media
it's just a convenience it's not a right
you guys with your oh freedom of speech
you know most of you don't even know
what that first amendment even
says you can't say whatever you want
people think they can say whatever you
want you can't slander someone
you can't yell fire in a movie theater
because if you
cause people to trample people because
you said a lie
and people die you will be
charged for that you can't you can't
incite violence you don't it's not
you the freedom of speech is not you can
say
whatever you want these are private
companies
and by the way our forefathers they
didn't know that there was going to be
internet
you know what i mean they didn't know
the world was different when the
constitution was written
in my opinion that sucker needs to be
torn up and you need to like start over
in like modern times
you know like you know or use it as a
foundation to be like okay let's
modernize this
because when they said you know your
right to bear arms
they didn't know it was gonna be guns
that could kill a hundred people in
three seconds
okay they didn't know that they didn't
think it was gonna be
the way it is right now we need to
modernize these things and think about
what's happening now
should social media be a part of like
what is considered the press
i think so i think social media should
be
it should fall under the same rules and
guidelines like you literally could say
whatever you want on social media about
anyone and there's no repercussions
the washington post can't do that
because they fall under like they are
the press
so that they have to have like they have
to have like three
proof that this is real you know you
know you know what i mean
they can't just write a story they can't
just say oh this person but now
in this era of social media people can
say whatever they want they can ruin a
man's life
off rumors and conjecture they can ruin
a man's life because somebody said
something no proof no trial nothing they
could just say
this guy is bad because this person said
it and that person said it
and no proof and a man's life is ruined
right twitter
and it's the convenience of it it's all
on everyone's phone
so all donald trump lost is the
convenience of reaching
reaching people and i think personally
i think it was wrong to ban the dude
from social media for the simple reason
that
you want to know what your enemies are
saying keep your friends close and your
enemies closer
now we're going to further fracture our
country
into divided sectors because all twitter
is now is just an
echo chamber for people that feel and
say the same thing over and over again
you know that's and that's what i can't
stand about you know progressive
liberal the liberal side of it is like
they just want they just live in an echo
chamber they just want to say the same
thing over and over and over again to
each other you know you look at award
shows and it's just
just smug [ __ ] on there you know i'm
gonna make a political statement right
now and
who's listening to this who's watching
because that's why the ratings
are terrible because they've alienated
70 million people who voted for trump
if you're a republican you also like
movies you turn on the oscars and you
want to say hey let me see if my
favorite movie won
and then some smug [ __ ] is on stage
talking about like well
trump trump trump they're like okay
click change the channel let's go over
to fox news or let's go over to
max news or let's go over to like let's
just go watch like you know
uh let's go watch the cartoon network or
whatever they just turn it off they're
not even listening to you anymore
so we're not even getting we're not even
hearing the other person other side i
actually like
i need to see what trump's saying i need
to i want to i want to be able to look
at twitter and be like
let me see what this dude is talking
about right now let me see what this
dude is saying let me make sure
let's see what's going on so yes he
should be punished
for inciting his his
part part of what he did to incite those
people
to embolden them even though guys they
already had it planned
people flew in people flew in for this
right they knew they were going to do
something and then
trump just helped fan the flames you
know he should be punished for that
but i don't think you should just remove
the dew completely from the
platform but i also understand you're a
part you're a private company
you're a private company and they ban
people all the time
it's not just him it's their right they
reserve the right to have whoever they
want on their private thing
even though it reaches hundreds of
millions of people like stop
acting like twitter is a right you
rather have
people think that everyone should be
born with a social security number and a
twitter handle
instead of healthcare you know what i
mean instead of like
uh now i'm just now i'm just going on
and on right now
well how much time how long have i been
on this damn thing it might be time to
get off soon
can i just digress into something else
real quick
i was which i was looking at just forbes
list uh it wasn't a forbes list but you
know how you get on the internet and
it'll be like
50 richest americans or me some list off
some website one of the people on the
list was this dude
i forgot his name but he's worth like 12
billion dollars and it said
it says how we got the money and the guy
it says hospitals
let me tell you something this is my
problem with the healthcare system
in the united states okay and maybe all
over the world
healthcare should not be for profit it
should pay for itself it should be one
of those things that we go
let's do this for our fellow man
okay all right let's do that let's make
sure our doctors and
are paid well let's make sure that those
people are you know those people are
paid well
but somebody that owns hospitals should
not be a billionaire
i have a problem with that what are you
doing
what are you doing why do you have a
billion dollar billions of dollars from
owning a hospital
that people that get into science do
they get into science for money
i guess i'm an optimist this way that i
like to think that people that get into
science they get in it because they want
to discover things
they want to make the world better you
know that they want to discover
something like
i want to discover a vaccine that can
cure cancer
is that do they do it because i want to
discover a vaccine so i can
sell this to everybody that has cancer
and make a lot of money
do you think that that's their main
focus i hope not
i'd like to think that that's not the
reason why they're doing it
i would like to think that they're doing
it to better
the world and that's what i feel like
healthcare should be about
yes make sure the doctors are well paid
make sure they make a million dollars a
year for all i care right
but should a dude be making 10 billion
off hospitals and we got people who
dying that can't get
insulin i just think that our priorities
are all messed up in that case right
there man
i just i really have a serious problem
with that
you know i don't know how you feel about
it but that's how i feel about it you
know and that takes me you know what i'm
going to go into another subject about
this it's
it's how i feel about the homeless as
well
guys i'm so tired of hearing about
people saying this a buddy of mine call
me
he's my he's a financial guy he's a
financial guy and he hit me up we're
just having a casual conversation i love
the guy you know
and he says to me he goes yeah man you
know
i'm considering leaving la because the
homeless problem
and i thought to myself the homeless
problem
there's always been a homeless problem
the homeless
la has always had a homeless problem the
problem now
is you're seeing it we've lived in this
world of
hear no evil see no evil say no evil
about the homeless
there's always been tense there's always
been people living and walking the
streets
so what's the acceptable amount of
homeless people for you that you feel
like
okay that's the good amount of homeless
people that i don't feel bad
like i'm so tired of people moving at
texas and then putting up videos on
their dumb ass social media
talking about oh look at the homeless
problem in l.a [ __ ] there's
homeless people in texas and austin too
you just don't see them because you're
living in a place where you don't have
to worry about it
they send them all to l.a because we
have enough land and the weather is
great
okay don't act like
la's the problem you the problem [ __ ]
you the problem
i'm the problem we are the problem now
we have to see it
and we don't feel good about it we feel
like oh man
because now we're recognizing that we're
not doing enough to help
other people we got the homeless all
over the place
people losing their lives people losing
their livelihood and they're living in
their car
people who like maybe six months ago
they had an apartment in a job
and now they're homeless and it's
growing now it's spilling over into our
neighborhoods where we're like oh wait a
minute i don't want to see this
you know what this reminds me of you
know what just reminds me of
i don't know if you guys ever saw the
movie beach with leonardo dicaprio
it was this movie so where these young
people went to this like
beach in thailand you know and they're
just having a great time
having sex and having fun well while
they were having
fun somebody got bit by a shark
and they had they had to like wrap their
leg up
and this person is just screaming and
hollering through the whole night
they're like ah
and everybody's annoyed everybody's like
oh my god
i don't want to hear that and then they
move that person to the other side of
the beach
and then shortly after everybody starts
having fun again because it was out of
sight out of mind
that's how you [ __ ] are with
the homeless
y'all just want to move them to the
other side of the beach y'all just want
to put them out of your sight mind so
you don't have to think about it
but nah man la's not the problem
you are don't sit there and act like
you're doing enough none of us are i'm
not you're not
you know if if if there's like
10 million people in the california
there's 40 million people in california
right man
if we all just gave 10 cents a week
to help the homeless problem and there
was some fun that we knew was being run
strictly for housing and food and
hospital
and medical care just for the homeless
we wouldn't have a homeless problem
if we knew that the money that we were
putting towards it
but it's just it's not happening and i
don't know what to do and i feel
terrible about it
i'm in my three-bedroom place and i'm
like you know
i'm like oh my god like you know there's
people that like
two blocks away there's tents
it's like stop putting up your videos
about la homeless
put up your videos about what you're
doing to help the homeless do that
so if you move into texas good for you
you move into
nashville good for you where they got
the homeless locked away someplace or
they don't have them there because the
weather is cold
those kind of places don't act like you
don't act like la's the problem
all you did was go i don't have to see
it i don't have to hear it i don't got
to talk about it
well you just got called out okay you
just got called out
because we're all sucking at helping our
fellow man
we all suck at it all right
i need to calm down
[Laughter]
all right let me see all right let me
look at my list
all right we talked about the first
amendment stop
stop stop talking about trump got his
freedom of speech taken away all right
you sound stupid it's a private company
you know it's a private company all
right
yeah i'm preaching today so what i'm in
a preachy mood okay go [ __ ] yourself how
about that is that preachy enough for
you
you get off my channel how about that
i'm in a preachy mood today because i'm
emotional and this stuff has been uh
building up inside me so this is what
exactly what
sometimes you you have that okay so
i don't care about you if you if you
feel that way so what
see this is what i'm saying people don't
want you know what i love that comment
that i just got in chat
you're funny but you're too preachy see
that's an example of how people feel
they want you to give them
the truth in a digestible way that they
can accept
people are preachy it comes off as
preachy when people are saying things to
you that you don't want to hear
then they use that as a way of getting
out of it you know
nah man sometimes sometimes you have to
hear the truth
in the same way though that i agree i am
highly emotional right now
i'm on i'm on one right now as you would
say okay so let me come down from that
and just to say all i want all i want
and i think we all want this
is we just want a better world we want a
better life for
all of us we want to be able to have
conversations i want to be able to like
you disagree with me and i might
disagree with you but can we come to a
common ground
can we agree to disagree but still live
in peace and harmony
there has to be a way to get to that
point and it has to come from our
leadership
you know right now it's just a country
is so divided we're just divided down
economic racial and political lines
all the time and it's like damn how can
we get past that
so we can just make this place better
because
in the core of it the rich are still
getting richer
you know poor people are still getting
poorer there's more poor people
you know coming out ever all every day
and you're worried about how i'm talking
to you
instead of worrying about what i'm
saying
this is what we have to try to get to
guys we got to try to get to a point
where we can just
have conversations
let's have conversations about
all the things that make us
uncomfortable and trust me
the homeless conversation makes me super
uncomfortable
i saw this youtube video the guy was
talking about well there's
seven or eight thousand people homeless
people in l.a now
and he was showing me they were showing
like they were driving down showing all
the tents and i was like
damn dude this is you know i'm like
oh man when that stuff is in your face
it really makes you uncomfortable
you know do i got oh you got to tell me
y'all
i got some uh i'm like i got some
something in my nose anyways
you have to uh
you have been oh oh see that takes away
from everything i was saying
it's hard to listen to somebody when
they got you know a booger in their nose
but you need to ignore that and hear the
truth
[Laughter]
i know yeah that's how people feel like
you know it's like what are you supposed
to do
ha ha what am i supposed to do myself
individually to help the homeless that's
that's that's the heart it becomes
daunting like
how do you do it like do you give money
and then just be like okay well that's
all i can do
hey i i support a shelter so now that
that absolves me from all guilt
i mean it's hard it's just like it's
really hard you know i don't have the
answers
and that's why i say i'm a part of the
problem i'm not just preaching at you
guys i'm preaching at myself
i really feel bad i'm a bleeding heart
you know and so
when you're a bleeding heart you either
do one of two things you
step up and do something about it or you
ignore it
and i've been one of those people that
i've just ignored it i just don't think
about it i just drive by the freeway and
i go oop don't look don't look don't
look
or i make myself feel better by i keep i
have change in my car and when i pull up
to a freeway arm ramp if somebody's got
a sign
i reach into my thing and i go here you
go buddy and i think whoo
that 75 cents i just gave that guy i'm
going to heaven because of that
you know what i mean so now what are you
now what do you do you know
it's like that's the thing it's like i
don't have the answers i'm not a
politician i'm just talking about it you
know
it's like it's like maybe people like me
who have a platform maybe we say to
everybody maybe if it's like
if it's not just me giving 75 cents
maybe i'm saying to all of you guys
if you have some money in your car it's
the money you don't need every time you
see somebody
help help i don't know what that does
but maybe maybe maybe it's gonna help
maybe if enough of us do that
we won't have this situation maybe uh
you know start
you know if there's a shelter near you
and you have extra food
give if you have extra toilet paper
because you have all that extra toilet
paper from uh
you know the pandemic give uh you know i
don't know what to do guys i wish i had
the answers you know
but the problem i'm really bringing i'm
not just talking about that we have a
homeless problem
the thing i'm bringing up right now is
we have
an empathy problem that we have that
the problem really is is that we're not
acknowledging the problem and trying to
do something about it
that to me is the the the greater issue
right now so
that's all i can say because even right
now as i'm looking at the chat you know
there's people that just like to be
disagreeable it's like
you know oh you're bringing up the
problem now what as if i'm wrong
so once again we're not discussing the
issue
so you're not hearing my sentiment
you're not hearing what i'm saying
this isn't a this isn't a time to be
fighting with me
i'm just bringing up what i feel like
we need to say is that the homeless
problem is not
la's fault it's our fault now the next
step is what do we do about it
i don't know tell me in chat what you
think we should do about it i'm saying
you know on the comments when it's time
for comments you know
write your comment like hey maybe we
could do this or you know
put up an organization that you think
that you want to support maybe we just
all start reaching out to like i said
shelters and organizations and food
banks and
blood drives and all the different
things i think if more of us get
involved maybe that'll help curb the
problem but
i don't know
well damn
i don't even know what to say now
ah that was a lot huh that was a lot uh
but other than that just to recap
once again r.i.p to my brother jeff
scott
and uh my condolences go out to all the
people in the
comedy store family all the people that
you know he touched their lives for so
many years he was around in the mitzi
shore era you know
he was just a wealth of knowledge you
know he was one of the last of the old
guard of people that were there in the
beginning you know
so you know my condolences go out to all
of us grieving today
for that and all of you too because
you've lost loved ones during this crazy
time or
or you know or you didn't get to say or
you're missing out so remember my main
message there in the beginning is to
reach out to people even casual friends
just reach out to people that
you normally saw all the time and you
kind of took it for granted because
it was just part of your routine you
know it was just like oh i go into
here's that that person i saw every day
at this and i didn't realize i'd never
see them again
you know maybe reach out to that person
you know use the social media for good
not just for trolling use social media
to be like hey you how you doing out
there just wanted to say hi
you know so do that
um what else uh you know hopefully we
can heal from this uh
this the the racial divide in our
country hopefully we can do something
about that you know i hope that these
people that attack the capital i hope i
hope that they
whatever else they have planned i hope
that it can be squashed and there's no
more
violence and no more death peacefully
protest man that's what the country's
founded on it's people being able to
protest that's not the way but you know
violent protest is a part of our history
and that's what i was reminded of by
people
when it was black people doing it when
there was black people doing it i had
all these people hitting me up talking
about
you don't know what this did to help
make change okay
it doesn't apply to these people can
they be violent to help make change
or not you quiet you quiet now you don't
want to so they don't
have a point even if their thing is not
whatever their thing is not justified
but in their minds it is to some of
those people
some of those people are hateful and
some of those people are just poor
some of those people are just people
that like they feel like they have no
voice for them you know i'm not saying
it's right
i am not saying it's right i'm not
justifying it at all i'm just saying
they they're going to use the same
justification as the other side did too
so
let's that's why get rid of all that
type of stuff
you know
um so we have that it's social media too
and like you know getting
banned on social media oh he got removed
from twitter i don't give a [ __ ]
okay it's a private company they're
about making money
okay they're they're not they're not for
the greater good
if you think twitter is for the greater
good you're a fool
right none of these places are for the
greater good they're about making
billionaires
that's all they are it's all they care
about
you know if they were for the greater
good it would just be it's not
government run okay it's not the post
office
it's a private company and they can
decide who the hell they want on their
private company
all right maybe the rules should change
maybe because something is so big and so
many people have access to it
it should fall under some there should
be some legislation about social media
now i think there should
i don't think you should just be able to
say whatever you want about anybody at
any time without having some
repercussions maybe just
maybe this is you know maybe everybody
should register and then
you know so you have your twitter you
can't have a twitter without having your
real information on there so people can
you could be held accountable
then i would be like all right it's a
right not a privilege
all right uh
yeah here's the same stupid comment
maybe start offering a couple of your
rooms to the homeless like
look do you want nobody's gonna do that
do you want to do that no that's not the
answer either you know like what what
you know what i mean like are we all
gonna do that this is ridiculous
that's not the answer either you know
see that that encourages people just to
be like
here we will say no evil that encourages
people to be like oh i don't want to be
a part of this because
if that's what you think the solution is
then that makes people like
turtle up i gotta turtle up and like
live in my own bubble you know
but by the way speaking of living in
your own bubble about social media
get out of your own bubble i think it's
a mistake to to to
to ban i i think i
i i don't like that they banned the guy
even though he should be punished for
what he did because i do think like you
need to hear all these voices you need
to hear them you need to see what
they're saying because now
he's just going to go to one of those
super right-wing ones
and we're never going to hear what he's
saying unless we look for it and then
once again we're living in alternate
universes where there's
there's a there's a ultra right-wing
universe and an ultra left-wing universe
and they're saying completely different
things about the same place that we're
living in
it's actually like it's that's dangerous
i think that's dangerous
so anyways i talked about that
you know maybe the forefathers the
forefathers didn't understand
they didn't know that they didn't know
about twitter maybe we should reconsider
some of the things in the constitution
and have like some real amendments that
are like
upgraded to what's happening in the
world now i don't know
that's how i feel about that but
i want to thank you for letting me get
all this out my venting episode of
riffing with griffin
thank you for being here i don't know if
i want to do this all the time
but it is what it is thanks for putting
up with my booger
my snotty nose for i don't know how long
that was i wasn't looking at chat enough
but
you know i was i was blubbering earlier
uh
but thank you for being here um remember
i game every day on
twitch eric griffin gaming so let me get
my plugs out
see even even after all that i'm still
i'm still being a businessman my damn
self see this it's you know
wow we're so self-centered and selfish
but i'm just being a hunt 100 and real
about it this is what it is
it's a podcast you know that is a source
of income right
uh so you can you can't do both see
i guess i guess that's the lesson there
is you can still
be about business and at the same time
still be about trying to help it doesn't
have to be one or the other
that's the crazy part about it right
there i guess i've learned from this
in this moment right now is it doesn't
have to be one or the other
we can all help we can all take care of
our families and still help other people
you know and that's let's look i don't
have the answer so in the next coming
weeks
let's let's help each other my
viewership let's help
each other figure out some things that
we could do let's share knowledge with
each other about
what can we do to help the homeless to
help this situation
hey the small this small group of people
we're not going to change the world but
we could change our world
so let's try to uh
let's try to do that you know what i
mean so
i guess that's all i have to say uh for
this week and
i don't know i appreciate you being here
i this has been cathartic for me i i
feel
that i got all that off my chest which i
normally would do on stage
so this is it feels like uh like i just
got off like doing like a 30 minute
power set after like some crazy [ __ ]
happened to me in my life and i had to
go get it off my chest
so i appreciate you guys being here
maybe when i look back at the tape i'm
gonna be like uh maybe i shouldn't have
said that or should have done it this
way
maybe i should have been less emotional
but i like doing it live because
it's i stand by what i say i do i don't
think
i'm not i'm not ashamed of anything
um of this uh so you know
thank you for being here and i
appreciate you and just
try to like listen to each other
and then once again reach out to your
loved ones
your liked ones reach out to people just
to let them know
hey i'm thinking about you and i hope
you're okay and i'm saying this to you
guys right now as you're watching me
i'm thinking about you and i hope you're
okay